when rohan agarwal decided to be a
doctor
he didn't expect to have to choose who
lives and who dies
a year before completing his medical
training
at the age of 26 he's in charge of an
emergency room in a new delhi hospital
on the night shifts
with a shortage of beds oxygen and
ventilators
he has to make heartbreaking decisions
what job we are assigned is what is to
be decided by god
whom to be saved whom not to be saved
and we are not made for that we are just
humans
and at this point of time we are being
told to do this
patients are continuing to die in india
because of a lack of critical care
facilities five died in the state of
uttarakhand when their oxygen supply ran
out on wednesday india's air force and
navy are now transporting oxygen and
other aid
while the army has joined the efforts to
create more facilities
this is one of india's biggest public
hospitals where the army is setting up
an oxygen plant based on technology
developed for its
fighter jets it says it will set up 500
similar plants
all over the country within three months
the plant can generate
1000 liters of oxygen every minute
this will operate continuously so
wherever such plants will be installed
those hospitals will not have to depend
on suppliers anymore
these plants are capable of transferring
oxygen to patients directly
but health experts say there's also a
shortage of medical workers with the
expertise to administer the aid
these are unprecedented in times we have
never seen a pandemic
of this size and scale and definitely a
pandemic
that that stresses the infrastructure
not only in terms of
beds etc but in terms of manpower
rohan agarwal takes a brief break to
have his lunch
but says the intensive care unit or icu
is never far from his mind
that beep sound is continuously in our
head even when we are sleeping that b
b b b that casualty noise the ic noise
that
continuously goes in our head in our
ears every time every day
with hospitals and their workers at
breaking point india's main opposition
party the congress is the latest to urge
the government to impose a nationwide
lockdown
elizabeth puranam al jazeera new delhi